ma tu come l'ho ucciso malissimo
che cosa ho fatto e poi tra l'altro c'è
uno che si chiama gigi d'alessio in
classifica e quindi non vorrei dire
quanti punti e due dai ragazzi mi
lasciate i miei punti per l'amor di dio
è sucai te lo meriti perché perché è
bello la madonna
cos'è sta roba addio gioco dell'anno
ragazze c'è la skin di gta 5 su nova beh
non ci credo ma santo iddio ma la quale
va bè sponge bob bell tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono i vj ed
oggi siamo su pikachu siamo su slitte
rio south park siamo su twitter in
versione posso anche cambiarono durante
la partita o cosa si possa cambiare
durante la partitella è vpn è
indemoniato le gare giochiamo seri lega
che tanto chi se ne fotte nella schifo
come eroina comatoso veicolato uno dei
ragazzi questo è l'inizio più ignorante
nella storia di slitte rio partiamo
seriamente con questo episodio di slitte
rio visto che ancora non ho iniziato a
fare nulla di serio però con l'atro al
face non posso fare partite di merda
anzi devo assolutamente vincerla tipo
adesso come culo non è un altro che
stanno morendo tutte attenzione in 212
perfetto l'avevo detto io all'inizio che
mi ammazzano va bene va bene va bene
grandissimo ma ora che sta andando da
dio
il troll face portafortuna ragazze
ricordiamoci la minaccia è provato è
racconto sto ragazzi che tipo voglio
posso fast a vita però con le stupido
io sono più stupido [ __ ] niente
ragazzi lasciamo perdere ciò che è un
prova dai che starà di allenamento
proviamo nei una seria in realtà la dico
sempre sta frase però voi fate finta di
niente
senti per caso male nel deretano no
perché tutto piazzato proprio bene bene
bene sparato lo ingloba del luogo non
luogo lo ingloba su ca
va beh ma zio mikati livida una
svegliata però capiamoci questa gara
partita troppo fugace ragazzi è tanta
roba
non vedo molto studio perché io e john
ward qui davanti porca di quella mi
faccio le partite della madonna poi per
guardare il punteggio crepo ma si può
proviamo per una volta nella una volta
sola nella vita a mettere il mio nick
non l'ho mai fatto ma il giocato all
inter io chiamandomi favi gen
cos'è solo perché mi chiamo fa vigendo
sparare ai punti dal culo mai finto ci
sono punti finti ma dai mela il kaiser
ha il tasso è che il tasto f mi fa
sparare i punti dal culo lessor voi vi
spiegate il perché adesso disegno un
pene bene non avrei capito l'utilità di
sta roba però riesco a sparare i punti
dal culo ragazzi quello che ogni volta
che succedono cosa dio santo devono
rompermi le palle perché bravissimo chi
sono questi di chi sono questa gente che
muove sostituto scemo
questa gente che è morta a caso ma
adesso sto di nuovo grosso col mio nome
è stranissimo ogni volta che divento più
grosso diventa inizia il casinò totala
affanculo brutto strappo che palle da
skin the spider man ma si può rega ma
veramente ma dai muggia che tra l'altro
è il non in classifica ma io l'ho
ammazzerò lo so lo sento ragazzi ma
attacco lui è il mio nemico giurato
[Musica]
ma tu come l'hai ucciso bellissimo che
cosa ho fatto
va be lega pro gaming pro gaming su
slitte rio rame madama cosa ho fatto
cioè non se l'aspettava mai poi stavo
per creare un idiota nome non se
l'aspettava ma ai ragazzi ho fatto
un'azione è la più la più bella azione
di slitte rio da quando ci gioco
incredibile che poi tra l'altro c'è uno
che si chiama gigi d'alessio in
classifica e quindi
non vorrei dino va beh questa è stata
veramente belli cento questo vita arriva
a 100 mila mi piace solo per st
minchiata deve arrivare a 100.000 live
veloce va bene tutti morti tutti i morti
non è la madonna giulia alessio ii se
gigi d'alessio e secondo io non posso
essere 43 smi rifiuti passate ragazzi
che ridiamo scherziamo poi magari
veramente gigi d'alessio che giocasse
l'isterico sì ma invece di discutere di
vigili adesso perché non ammazzo sto
tizio tipo cosimato nome come io l'ho
messo male nel dell'età noemi fotoni
punti e io faccio le provate con i
fotoni punti e due dai ragazzi mi
rilasciati i miei punti per l'amor di
dio è sucai te lo meriti
malin globo ti puoi fare in così tuoi
per una volta nella vita melissa va
inglobando ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
ci ho fatto inglobato lo inglobato il
sangue mi dispiace ragazza che ti uccido
così però devo ceva sono nono quanti
punti ci 12.000 sono quarto wow dovrei
riuscire a tornare primo dov'è ma non
posso perché c'è suo figlio di un verme
porca vacca l'hai data la madonna chi è
quello c roba tutti ciclope rai
maledetto phantom senti phantom via
della pillola
dai che magistrato eccole morto sapevo
che sarebbe morto grande erika l'ha
uccisa una che si chiama erika grazie
erika se in tutti noi
viva l'italia solo 23esimo ragazzi mi
sono pappati frutti di quel poveraccio
che ho preso di mira eccoci qua detto
erika mi spiace però non me davis cassar
cazzo
[Musica]
vacca e vabbè grande attenzione
meno male era simile a me non l'avevo
visto mi stavo facendo ammazzare un
idiota grandissimo la madonna va
velocissimo tutti i miei ragazzi questi
tutti i miei mi dispiace erika scusami
però dovevo farlo è stato più forte di
me
tag 13.000 quanto sono però madonna così
primo sono tipo tra i primi quasi e
vabbè tutti i morti fosse così ci arrivò
prima attenzione 14.500 no al primo st
15 mila che cazzo di sfiga quarto è
morto che questo caso non si è
schiantato con sono quarto veramente
facendo come pensi veramente di
inglobarli che sei alto un metro e un
cazzo ma che boy o ai ostinato proprio
ma non mi margine la vedi la lunghezza
che differente non ce l'hai più grosso
di me mi amor e godo vi giuro veramente
godo godo manco tua mamma
ero arrivato secondo
e andata bene che non ho visto il nome
non mi ricordo come ti chiami che sono
ti veniva cerca a causa direttamente
come ho fatto a morire così porca vacca
un deficiente come un deficiente sono
morto come un [ __ ] liste pisodio
fatto l'uccisione più bella e la morte
più brutta da quando gioca slither io
cioè nanda non devasteranno all ingro
apparso tutti ma non ci riuscirà a
nessuno zio bravi soprattutto ubriaco è
morto è morto non muore questura ubriaco
per uno è morto come di portare questo
cani quella vacca laida ma che cazzo ci
ferma levati dalle palle
ma chi era ma chi era non posso morire
così non è possibile c'è veramente mi
rifiuto è certo ovvio se ero io ero
molto tre volte forse si schiatta
grandissimo sono miei mezzi delle foto
tutti mi spiace
ok ok in globo globo a che culo ok sto
scherzando
bene bene bene sono miei sono mio e luca
e 66 straccio scusami ma famiglia vi
basta strage sto facendo perché perché
ma che molti sto facendo in questo
episodio ma non è possibile un perfetto
perfetto perfetto non sono miei
cioè incredibile e morte morte morte
morte morte morte morte morto tutti che
arrivano a rompere le palle tutti team
trump
ma come come file search team di donald
trump sull'iter io uccido io dai team
trump fammi vedere che sai fare fa vj
versus donald trump niente ho vinto fa
vigenti anche sono durato più di donald
trump però almeno in sosta soddisfazione
grandissima azione zio bravo grazie ai
punti e non mi avete cazzo se glielo
presi è che palle c'è la fine ma dpa un
tutti loro sempre come si è salvata una
perfetta e tutto scema senso più grosso
di dei due metri ma che voi va a mazzi
ma da svegli ma questo è scemo
vabbè ma guarda che idiota che casino
saporito tutti uno no non è morto per
niente vabbè ma quasi
vabbè è lo sapevo io porto
[Musica]
lucido dai sì sì sì i miei punti in
piedi profitti lo ammazzo che non me ne
frega niente aver ucciso questo mi
ammazzo lui era un conto in sospeso
8 sul 9 2 su 3 2 sul 3 manca al 3 c'è un